britain is set to suspend its
extradition treaty with hong kong amid
growing international condemnation
of china's new national security law in
the territory
now this controversial law punishes a
broad rage range of offenses that are
considered
a subversion terrorism or collusion with
foreign elements
that did not stop pro-democracy
activists from holding an
unofficial primary election hoping to
come up with enough candidates to win a
majority in the legislature later this
year
on monday prominent pro-democracy
activist joshua wong submitted
his application to run in the poll
another one of hong kong's most
prominent
young activists nathan law recently fled
hong kong to london
where our reporter charlotte caught up
with him
it's not all new to nathan law in london
the left-hand
traffic he says reminds him of hong kong
his home which he fled
two weeks ago the new security law made
it impossible for the activists to stay
i myself are in great danger under the
law
but also a lot of my fellow activists in
hong kong
so a lot of us are were under
huge stress and fear of being prosecuted
i'm meeting law in central london the 27
year old brought this banner all the way
from hong kong
a banner that could now get him arrested
at home
and a reminder of what he is fighting
for freedom
it says in chinese the activist does not
want to disclose his exact location and
plans because he's concerned for his
safety
we all know that china's reach could be
very extensive
um for me i'm constantly moving and
being
extremely careful and cautious about
everything
so i hope that i could protect myself it
was an
umbrella that once made law famous when
alongside thousands of other hong
kongers he
protested for democracy in 2014.
together with joshua wong he founded the
pro-democracy opposition party democisto
and got elected to the city's de facto
parliament
now law has had to leave his life in
hong kong behind
these are um very painful decision
but for me i think it's more than myself
it's more than a personalization
it's a strategy for the movement because
we we need to have someone to speak on
the international level freely
on hong kong people's demand when they
cannot speak up
on the ground so for me i i would love
to
bear that responsibility even though i
need to have some personal sacrifice
law came to london on a visitor visa
with one clear purpose
he wants to be the strong voice for
those still fighting the fight back in
hong kong
but who are now being silenced under the
new security law
yeah it's a historical time for uk
regarding the china policy
there's a huge change in the past six
months
that i think is a cross-isle
a strong consensus in the uk politics
that we have to be more assertive to
china
and i hope that my presence and my
engagement
in the uk could facilitate that change
that we could hold china accountable in
the future
we have sense of law wants to empower
the movement
and his fellow activists from abroad but
the reality of not knowing if
and when he can return to hong kong in
the future leaves him sad
it's just like um
it's a waiting that you don't know when
it will end and i
i also care a lot of responsibility on
my shoulder for now
and i have to remind myself i i don't
live
for myself but for the whole movement
it's a lonely path
that nathan law has chosen but one where
he believes he can be the most useful
to the cause
for more on this story let's go to hong
kong where our correspondent phoebe kong
is standing by for us
hi phoebe we saw there that nathan law
is now in london and we also mentioned
that britain
is looking set to suspend its
extradition treaty with hong kong
does the democracy movement there see
britain as a safe haven
well britain's latest move is expected
to further escalate its
um uh inspirations and tensions with
china that um
the the uk actually follows it after
many of his airlines including u.s
um canadians and uh australia
suspended his expedition treaty with
hong kong
so um hong kong's uh controversial
national security law is only one of the
reasons
that triggers controversy between
britain and china that um
apart from that the uk has recently
announced that to remove or ban
chinese telecommunication giants far
away from
its 5g networks and the uk government is
also under pressure from its ruling
party members that
to sanction certain chinese officials
who violate
uh who get involved in human rights
abuses
so um from the perspective of beijing is
ambassador in hong kong in london has
already warned
that beijing will uh wrestle
react to any kind of like sanction
towards chinese officials
so um in the future it's expected that
the tension between
the uk and china is going to intensify
in the short coming future
meanwhile we've been looking at some
pictures of another a prominent
pro-democracy movement founder joshua
wong
and he's just announced that he'll stand
for the election to the legislative
council in hong kong but
will he be allowed to stand
well this is a big question remain an
answer at this moment
that joshua has joshua wong has just
signed up for
like running for the upcoming
legislative election this is not the
first time for him to run for election
he did so last september last november
in
another local election but then he uh
was far
like from running at that election so um
it's been closely watched that whether
he can like actually like um
run for this this election especially
under the newly
implemented national security law which
clearly stated that
anyone who doesn't uphold the national
security law
um may face like maybe bought from
running for public office
so for many observers and analysts in
hong kong it's been closely watched at
how the government will handle the
upcoming election
and how they will interpret the new law
and to screen candidates like in the
coming few weeks
our correspondent phoebe kong reporting
for us thank you very much
you